John F. Kennedy served as the 35th President
of the United States, before he was killed
in 1963.
While we all know about JFK, chances are that
you probably know more about the conspiracy
theories surrounding his assassination that
the actual details of his life.
This story goes far deeper than just the individual
life of John F. Kennedy.
In order to understand the man, you need to
know the family- and he was far from being
the only one whose life ended in tragedy.
On today’s Biographics, we will discuss
the real man behind the Presidency.
The Kennedy Family History
The Kennedys have been called “American
Royalty”, and to the outside world, they
were a symbol of the American dream.
It all started when Patrick Kennedy married
Bridget Murphy, who emigrated from Ireland
to the United States in the 1800’s.
Patrick died at an early age, leaving Bridget
a widow and single mother.
She became a full-time maid for a wealthy
family in Boston.
After a few years, though, Bridget Kennedy
managed to save her money, and opened up a
general store.
Her only son, Patrick Jr., was called “PJ”,
and at 14 years old, he started working in
the general store with his mother.
When he was in his 20’s, PJ opened an Irish
pub.
He made so much money, that he purchased a
bar in an upscale hotel, as well as a local
bank.
PJ’s son, Joseph P. Kennedy, would be the
first to grow up enjoying the fruits of his
ancestor's labor.
He went to Harvard University, where he got
a taste for high society.
Unfortunately, though, Joseph was snubbed
by a lot of his classmates, and denied from
entering several fraternities.
While it’s hard to imagine now, there was
actually a huge stigma against Irish Catholics
back then, especially among the American elite.
Most of the upper-class American families
were descended from British Protestants, who
taught their children that the Irish were
low-class, good-for-nothing drunks.
This stereotype only motivated Joseph Kennedy
to become a millionaire, and prove everyone
wrong.
Joseph Kennedy married the Mayor of Boston’s
daughter, Rose Fitzgerald.
They went on to have 9 children together.
The oldest son was named Joseph Jr., and even
as an infant, his parents would say that he
would grow up to be the President of the United
States.
His second son, John Fitzgerald Kennedy was
born on May 29, 1917, but everyone called
him “Jack”.
Rose would go on to have seven more children,
and they all grew up watching their father
work hard to make his first million before
age 35.
In the 1920’s, Joseph Kennedy was hustling
to make as much money as he could, by any
means necessary.
He took advantage of prohibition by buying
up the alcohol just before the laws were scheduled
to change.
He ran speakeasies together with a man named
Sam Giancana, who was connected to the Chicago
Mob.
He also played the stock market, and made
millions running schemes that would now be
considered illegal today.
Before long, Joseph Kennedy became the richest
Irish Catholic in the United States.
Since he was always trying to climb the ladder
for more money and power, Joseph Kennedy began
to get involved in politics.
President Franklin Delano Roosevelt was impressed
by Kennedy’s wit and charisma, so he was
appointed as the Ambassador to Great Britain.
Considering that he had spent his entire life
trying to prove that Irish men could be just
as successful as the English, this was the
cherry on top of Kennedy’s accomplishments.
And the only way it could get better would
be if one of his sons became President someday.
JFK’s Early Years
Jack Kennedy was an adorable baby with big
blue eyes.
But even during his earliest days in life,
he was already very sick.
By age 3, he already had whooping cough, chicken
pox, the measles, and scarlet fever.
Jack was also diagnosed with a condition called
Addison’s Disease.
He spent a lot of his young life living in
the hospital.
His parents were told by doctors that he may
not survive until adulthood.
However, Jack was a very happy kid, and he
had a lot of love for life.
Friends and relatives say that he never complained
about his illnesses, and that he was always
smiling and making jokes.
His siblings made light of his condition,
joking that if a mosquito bit him, it would
die instantly.
The Kennedy children grew up meeting members
of the British aristocracy from a young age,
so they were taught traditional etiquette.
They became this uniquely all-American family
who had the charm of British royalty.
While most of the children were living with
their father in London, both Jack and his
older brother Joe Jr. attended a private High
School called Choate Rosemary Hall in Connecticut.
Joe Jr. was the most popular guy in school,
and the all-around golden boy.
He was a varsity football player who was good-looking,
outgoing, charismatic, and got straight A’s.
Jack, on the other hand, was the polar opposite
of his older brother.
Because of his disease, he grew up feeling
as if every day may be his last, so he was
constantly living life to the fullest.
He got C’s in every subject, except English
and History.
Just like his father, Jack got some backlash
from his peers for being Irish.
Some of the other kids called him “mucker”,
because that was the nickname given to Irish
men who would clean up the horse manure in
the stables of English nobles.
Instead of sulking, Jack countered the bullies
by embracing the name, and even proudly wore
a necklace with a gold shovel charm.
He created a group on campus called The Mucker’s
Club, and they dedicated their free time to
playing crazy pranks around campus.
Soon enough, being a “mucker” wasn’t
a derogatory term anymore.
It was a badge of honor.
Some of the most popular boys in school joined
his club so they could “raise hell.”
If YouTube had existed back then, there is
no doubt that they would have been filming
pranks like David Dobrik's Vlog Squad.
In fact, Jack Kennedy was plotting a prank
where they were going to bring in a huge pile
of horse manure into the middle of the school’s
dance floor, and take photographs of the students
and treacher’s reactions when they opened
the doors.
When the Dean caught wind of this plan, he
called in Joseph Kennedy for a parent-teacher
conference.
Jack was nearly kicked out of school, but
his father stepped in and prevented him from
being expelled.
With a wink and a smile, Joseph Sr. was teaching
Jack that he didn’t have to play by the
rules of normal people, because the Kennedys
could always pay someone off.
Unfortunately, Jack’s recklessness would
catch up to him, when he became seriously
injured during a football game.
He ruptured a disc in his back, and it took
months of surgeries and time in the hospital
before he could walk again.
He never fully recovered, and would be in
pain for the rest of his life.
Becoming a War Hero
After graduating from High School, Jack went
to Harvard.
Outside of class, he joined the swimming and
sailing teams, and was known for being a lady’s
man.
Even though he had more of a passion for English
literature, his father pushed him to study
political science and law.
He also arranged for him and his older brother
Joe Jr. to get summer jobs in the American
Embassy in London.
Jack and his father would send letters back
and forth about politics, and when World War
II began, he already had plenty of insider
knowledge about what was going on in Europe.
For his senior thesis, Jack wrote a book called
Why England Slept, which basically reiterated
his father’s beliefs about how he believed
Great Britain was not prepared for World War
II.
It became a bestseller, and it established
the name John F. Kennedy as a political expert
at an early age.
While Jack was finishing up his degree at
Harvard, his father, Joseph Kennedy Sr. was
dealing with the very real possibility that
the United States would join in World War
II.
Even though he was living in London at the
time, Joseph Kennedy made it very clear that
he was an “isolationist”, which meant
that he did not want America to join the war.
And in 1940, he made a comment to the press
that he believed that he could negotiate a
peace treaty with Adolf Hitler.
Because of this statement, people assumed
that he was a Nazi sympathizer, and he was
forced to step down as the Ambassador.
Jack and his older brother, Joe Jr. both wanted
to join the Navy after the United States officially
entered World War II in 1941.
When Jack went through the medical examination,
he was rejected because of his past back injury.
But his father paid off the army officials
to let him pass.
Joe Jr. went on to be a pilot in Europe, while
Jack worked as the commander of a torpedo
ship in the South Pacific called “PT-109”.
His back was in near-constant pain, but suffered
in silence.
Swimming and sailing every summer paid off
for Jack in a huge way, because during the
war, PT-109 was attacked by the Japanese,
and it began to sink.
He spent three hours swimming around the wreckage,
making sure he had accounted for all of up
the survivors.
One of the men, Patrick McMahon, was badly
burned over his body, and could hardly move.
Kennedy was the strongest swimmer of the group,
so he had to tow Patrick McMahon by pulling
a string from his lifejacket with his teeth.
He lead his men as they swam three miles to
a nearby island for safety, and they were
rescued a week later.
When Jack returned home, he weighed only 120
pounds, and he was in excruciating pain.
He had to wear a back brace and walk with
a cane for several months.
He was awarded the Navy and Marine Corps Medal
for his service.
The entire family celebrated his bravery by
throwing him a party.
Jack’s older brother, Joe Jr., came home
for the party, but he felt a deep sense of
shame, because he never did anything to prove
that he was a war hero.
In an attempt to be like his younger brother,
Joe accepted an extremely dangerous mission
to carry sensitive explosives in a plane.
But before he could complete the mission,
the plane exploded in midair.
Joseph Kennedy Jr. died at just 29 years old.
Becoming President
Jack Kennedy never wanted to be President
of the United States.
He was very much a free spirit, and wasn’t
very suited for politics.
He always said that he wanted to be a writer
who sailed around the world.
But now that Joe Jr. was gone, his father
turned to Jack to fulfill all of his hopes
and dreams.
Even though he didn’t have very much experience
in politics, his father used his money and
connections to propel JFK’s career.
Supported by their father, his siblings pitched
in by spending a lot of their time running
Jack’s campaign as their full-time job.
Through his late twenties and early thirties,
he quickly moved up to The House of Representatives,
and then the Senate.
In 1953, Jack Kennedy married Jacqueline Bouvier.
She was a young socialite and a writer at
the Washington Time Herald.
Just like Jack, she had also been groomed
by her wealthy east coast family to be the
perfect First Lady.
She could speak French, Italian, and Spanish
fluently, which aided her later on in international
diplomacy.
Soon after marrying Jacqueline, JFK wrote
his second book, called Profiles of Courage,
which won a Pulitzer Prize.
In 1960, JFK became the democratic nominee
for the presidency when he was just 43 years
old.
The public loved Jack Kennedy because he seemed
just like any other normal guy.
He spoke with a Boston accent, and he wasn't
afraid to visit factories to shake the hand
of the average American.
Even though he came from this wealthy family,
people knew that the Kennedys were self-made,
and saw that he was very down-to-earth.
Young voters of the 1960’s were eager for
change, and he represented their ideal American.
When he moved in to the White House in 1961,
Jack placed his younger brother Bobby as the
new Attorney General even though he was only
35 years old.
Despite the fact that the brother did not
have much experience, Kennedy chose trusted
advisors who he could trust to help him navigate
the Presidency.
The media was obsessed with The Kennedys.
Jackie would appear in magazines showing off
her interior design skills at the White House,
and her French fashion that was always front
page news.
What they didn’t know is that behind the
scenes, she was his rock.
She would help him by translating foreign
books and documents for him all through the
night, while also giving him a place to call
home outside of work.
He loved spending time with his two children,
John Jr. and Caroline.
Friends said that the oval office was always
filled with the kid’s toys, and the first
thing he did every morning was watch cartoons
and eat cereal with them.
Despite having such a beautiful young family,
JFK was known for having not-so-secret affairs.
Rumors circulated that he was dating the buxom
movie star Marilyn Monroe, and phone records
prove that she frequently called the White
House.
But for all of his secret affairs, Jackie
never strayed from her loyalty.
She knew about his infidelity, and considered
getting a divorce, but chose to stay together
for the sake of Jack’s political career.
In later interviews, Jackie said that her
and Jack never stopped appreciating the fact
that they were lucky enough to live in the
White House.
She described it as constantly feeling like
a kid on Christmas, because they were always
gushing over the history that surrounded them.
They never took a moment for granted.
The Kennedy’s youthful enthusiasm is often
credited for pushing America through the Space
Race, and JFK would help bring America to
the moon.
Jack gave the impression that he genuinely
enjoyed his job as President very much.
He was known for smiling in the middle of
a question from a journalist, because he had
already thought of a witty comeback.
He treated his press conferences almost like
an audience for the jokes he wrote in his
spare time.
One day, he was holding a piece of paper as
if he was about to say something incredibly
serious to the crowd.
He looked up, and said, “The chimpanzee
was flying in space.
Took off at 10:08.
He reports that everything is perfect, and
working well.”
He smiled, and the room burst out in laughter.
Saving the Country From Nuclear War
Even though he was always smiling for the
press, John F. Kennedy was an expert at hiding
his pain.
He has been credited for saving the United
States from The Cuban Missile Crisis, and
prevented nuclear war.
During the Eisenhower administration, the
CIA was planning to invade Cuba to bring down
the Communist leader, Fidel Castro.
When JFK was sworn into office in January
of 1961, he was briefed on the plan that was
already underway.
This was the famous mission known as The Bay
of Pigs, and unfortunately, it completely
failed.
After this, Fidel Castro captured American
soldiers and threatened the United States
with nuclear bombs.
After a series of negotiations, Kennedy agreed
to send $53 million in baby food and medication
over to Cuba in exchange for the lives of
American prisoners.
By 1962, the threat of nuclear war had subsided.
In a collection of interviews called The Jackie
Kennedy Tapes, we learn that it was terrifying
for the young couple to enter office and immediately
have such a huge burden on their shoulders.
During the Cuban Missile Crisis, JFK was so
upset about the possibility of nuclear war,
that he hardly slept, and one day bled into
the next.
She also said that they had a conversation
about what to do in case of an attack.
Jacqueline was more than willing to die with
Jack.
She said that if there was not enough time
to get to the bunker, she would stand beside
him on the White House Lawn to watch the world
end.
Jack Kennedy truly did care very much for
the American people, and he loved them, even
if he didn’t know them personally.
His wife, Jackie, said that he would often
come home sobbing whenever he heard any tragic
news of Americans dying.
He had first-hand experience serving in World
War II, so the last thing he wanted was for
the United States to get involved in the Vietnam
War.
The media accused him of being soft on Communism,
but he was firm on his decision.
If he was still alive to complete his second
term, there is a very real possibility that
the 58,220 Americans who died in Vietnam would
still be alive.
But as we know, his predecessor, Lyndon B.
Johnson, declared war on Vietnam in 1964.
The Assassination
On November 22nd, 1963, John F. Kennedy and
his presidential motorcade were driving through
the streets of Dallas, Texas.
Jack was waving to the crowd and sitting next
to his wife, Jackie, in the back of the 1961
Lincoln Continental.
The Governor of Texas, John Connelly, and
his wife were sitting in front of them.
Just as they were passing the Texas School
Book Depository, at least three shots were
fired.
Jack was hit in the neck, and the next was
a fatal headshot.
At least one of the bullets also hit John
Connelly.
John F. Kennedy was pronounced dead, and Vice
President Lyndon B Johnson assumed the role
of President of the United States.
The entire country was stunned.
Everyone who was alive back then remembers
exactly where they were when Jack Kennedy
was killed, and the entire nation mourned
their President.
A man named Abraham Zapruder was in the crowd
during that attack, and he filmed the parade
with his 8mm camera.
He was not the only one filming that day,
but he captured the clearest picture of what
actually happened.
Once Lyndon B. Johnson became the new President,
he ordered an investigation known as The Warren
Commission to examine the facts of the shooting,
including a frame-by-frame analysis of the
Zapruder Film.
The head of the CIA, Allen Dulles, was one
of the men on that committee, and many believe
that his influence completely manipulated
the results of the investigation.
The Warren Commission came to the conclusion
that Lee Harvey Oswald worked alone.
He was already under investigation for collaborating
with the Soviet Union, and being a potential
terrorist.
He also worked at the Texas School Book Depository,
which is where he had set up his gun.
Before he could be questioned in court, Oswald
was killed just two days later by a man named
Jack Ruby.
The incident was broadcast on live TV.
All of this seemed too convenient, and plenty
of people believe that there was a much larger
conspiracy at hand.
Now, there are a lot of theories out there
about who was behind JFK’s assassination,
so keep in mind that we will never have enough
time to go over all of them in this video.
Just one of the many reasons why people find
The Warren Commission so hard to believe is
the fact that only three shell casings were
found that were fired by Lee Harvey Oswald.
Two out of the three bullets were shattered
upon impact, leaving tiny fragments behind.
However, there is one bullet that supposedly
traveled through both John F Kennedy and Governor
Connally’s bodies, and yet somehow, it remained
completely intact.
This idea is called “the magic bullet theory”,
and it is honestly really hard to believe.
Many people believe that there were far more
than just three shots fired, and that there
was a second gunman.
They believe this third bullet was planted
in the car afterwards by the CIA.
If there was more than one shooter, there
is the very real possibility that multiple
people were behind plotting his death, and
the CIA wants us to believe it was just one
crazy American-hating-terrorist.
One of the only ways to prove that there were
other shots fired would be if we saw the proof
on video.
There was supposedly a different angle filmed
of the shooting by a man named Orville Nix,
which is called “The Grassy Knoll Footage.”
He sold one copy to the local press for $5,000,
and he gave the second copy to the FBI.
In this film, there is supposedly evidence
that there was a second shooter hiding behind
the bushes in a grassy knoll.
However, the government seized the footage,
and Nix claims that when it was given back,
there were sections of the tape that had been
removed.
Orville Nix’s granddaughter, Gayle Nix Jackson,
sued the US government for 10 million dollars
or getting her family's original film back,
but they claim to no longer have it.
In 2017, the CIA declassified thousands of
records about the JFK assassination that had
never been seen by the public.
While it gives more insight to the case, it
does little to fuel the fire of any particular
conspiracy theory.
We may never know the whole story of what
happened during JFK’s assassination.
And if there truly was a cover-up, we have
no control over what has been done in the
past.
If he could see what happened to his legacy,
surely, Jack would want us to remember that
he lived everyday like it was his last.
And when asked if he had any regrets, he only
said, “I wish I had more good times”.
We leave you with the words of Jacqueline
Onassis Kennedy;
“Jack was young, and loved...y’know, everything.
Jack was the most un-self-conscious person
I had ever seen.
He could naturally be attractive in a crowd,
in a room.
It was like having so many things in common
with the many sides of you.
Everyone found apart of themselves in Jack.”